hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
so in a previous video I said that I was
planning to read the book lifespan why
the age and why we don't have to buy
David Sinclair and guess what I read it
so in this video I'll give my thoughts
and opinions and a general overview to
the book so all in all I really enjoyed
reading it and I think the book is very
accessible to those who have with a
science background and a nun science
background the book also addresses many
current issues and also informs on the
status that were active understanding
lifespan and health span and humans so
the book is called lifespan there it
could quite easily be also called health
fan since it discusses and quite a lot
of detail the science behind book
regulates and could be modified to
extend a health span but also elicits
the societal impacts which is also a
topic of conversation that really does
need to be spread so the first
subheading of the book is why we age and
so I've made several videos before about
the different hallmarks of aging but
what I really liked about this book is
that David's from all of his years of
research has provided his own idea about
what comes before these four months of
Aging and he described soul in his
informational theory of aging and what
are the key messages that David Sinclair
likes to make in this book is that aging
is quite simply loss of information and
interestingly this information theory of
aging by David is based upon the
mathematical theory of communication by
Claude Shannon and to make this point
clear you need to understand that there
are two ways of transmitting information
digital and analog what are the main
differences being that analog
information is continuous whilst digital
is discrete the problem with analog
information however is that you can get
disrupted by noise and so David makes
the point that we have both analog and
digital information within each of our
cells the digital information being our
genetic codes whereas the analog
information being the epigenetic codes
that determines and dictates the gene
expression levels and how different
regions of DNA is compacted within the
cell and so based upon the Claude
Shannon's work we know that it's analog
information that is prone to the
accumulation of noise and disruption
over time and so if this is the
epigenetic information then this
epigenetic information can also
accumulate noise over time and this
results in a loss of information which
David summarizes has been the key reason
behind the aging process so I really
like how David uses this theory of
communication as a framework on which to
build the idea of how we age because
aging is very complicated and this
provides a simpler way of understanding
the process but to use another analogy
from the book it's like a DVD whereby
the digital information is recorded on
the DVD but DVD surface could get
scratched and that scratching of the
surface this analog information can
disrupt the reading of the digital
information encoded on the DVD so we've
discussed what aging is the next parts
of the book looks at is it possible to
prevent or even to reverse this aging
process so the next part of the book
takes us much more into the science
behind the aging process built upon work
from the only Davis lab from other labs
as well and so to be quite blunt he
suggests that there are three main ways
that you can do to try and prevent or
slow down the aging process one is to
eat less so what this effectively is is
calorie restriction and so I've made a
video before in this which I'll link up
this up for you and see how this relates
to the aging process is you can try and
think of it as having normal biology and
how just you know the way cells are you
can accumulate damage within proteins
within the different lipids and within
DNA itself and also the epigenetics as
we've already discussed and so if you
have high nutrient sediment you kind of
promote this you have an increased raise
this normal biology process which is
just increases the rate of damage so the
idea is that color restriction it could
reduce the amount of damage induced
within the cell but also activate
processes that can help to reverse the
damage that's accumulated so
conceptually this can be quite a hard
topic to get your head around but David
describes it in his book was such
simplicity as well as back
up of evidence from research from his
lab and from other labs as well I also
appreciate how he tries to share the
science without enforcing any opinions
over how exactly you should be doing any
of this but if you are interested in
calorie restriction in humans then you
should definitely check out my video
where I discussed this recent paper
where they had a two-year study looking
at the effects that's calorie
restriction hats but anyway back to the
book review the next stage of the book
is to look at what process is involved
with color restriction but also looking
at the molecules out there that can
mimic this restriction process and
looking at molecules that can target
these different proteins
so the different molecular pathways that
I'm drawing out here are often referred
to as the nutrient signaling pathways
and so if they're unfamiliar to you at
the moment don't worry the book does
explain them in quite a lot of detail
I'm just summarizing it there but their
key point I'm trying to make is that
there are different molecules that can
target different proteins within these
pathways to modulate the signaling
through the pathway at least based on
current research that's what we think
they're doing so the different molecules
discussed in the book included rapamycin
metformin resveratrol and nad precursors
and the idea is that you want to be able
to promote the stretch resistant
signaling and she prevents the Grove
signaling to prevent or slow down aging
and in a way this should mimic calorie
restriction so one molecule discussed in
great depth is metformin which you may
already be taking because it's a type 2
diabetes drug but now as you learn from
the book metformin is being tested to
see if it can actually target aging
itself and so this targeting aging with
metformin is the trial that recently
started and it's trying to look to see
if metformin can delay the onset of
age-related diseases the problem is is
that this is a really good step forward
but currently aging the still isn't
recognized as a disease so if there is a
link between metformin
and preventing aging you'd have to be
prescribed the drug so you'd have like
time to diabetes Alice
how I think it works but some of the
other molecules disgusts you can already
have access to the second one being
resveratrol so resveratrol is thought
she prevents the aging process by
activating certains and fresh virtual
can be found in amongst things grapes
and also in red wine but as you learn in
the book to get the same dose of
resveratrol as has been used in
experimental studies you would have to
drink a lot and a lot of wine and the
last sets of molecules
that's from experimental studies seem to
slow the aging process are nad
precursors one of which is n MN or
otherwise ona's nicotinamide
mononucleotide and so and nad precursors
you can buy from different companies and
people are taking them and however some
of them can be quite costly and this is
yet to be scientifically proven that
they have an impact in humans however I
really did enjoy the story that David
gives of his own father who started
taking nmn and has had this like
rejuvenation of life come back to him
which I thought was quite an inspiring
and interesting story and it really adds
a personal element to the book which I
really enjoyed like Chris Farrell do n
MN can also come for your diet
it's found in broccoli cucumber avocado
tomatoes and edamame however as with
resveratrol you need to eat a lot and a
lot of broccoli to get the dose of nmn
that matches what you can take with
documents so the second way to prevent
aging is to exercise more but it's just
discussed in more detail in the book but
it also is thought to Absolut activating
these stress resistance pathways within
a cell and lastly it's to go outside the
thermo neutral zone so temperatures
above and below what our bodies are
comfortable with so exactly how going
for a walk in the cords can help prevent
the aging process
it's entirely clear yet but again it's
thought to activate these stress
resistant pathways but I did learn from
the book that it's not sauna
it's Sona but like David says I think
I'm also going to stick with sauna so as
the book explains we've come a long way
in understanding the aging process but
there are still some key
aspects to the aging process that we are
yet to fully understand and David
explains us again by building upon
Claude Shannon's theory it's a
mathematical theory of communication and
how you can recover lost information
that's lost in the analog signaling
process very noise accumulation so Dave
explains using this principle that there
are three key aspects that we need to
identify to be able to recover the
information loss during aging so one we
need to identify what the observer is
that recognizes the original signal we
then need to know where the correction
data is stored and also what is the
correct in device that seems to be able
to reverse and remove the noise from the
signal to get you back the original
signal so in addition to the advances
made in science that you'll learn about
in the book you'll also learn about the
technological advances that have also
occurred one of which is biometric
tracking or bio tracking so this part of
the book reminded me a lot of what I
read in Eric tables most recent book
deep medicine for which I also did a
book review then I'll link up the top
view but in a similar way to bio
tracking he talks about virtual medical
assistants which are kind of things you
could have on your phone that could
inform you of all your different
biometrics how much you slept how your
composition of your blood is doing what
features should be taking etc and that
is definitely it seems to be the way
that technology is going in this
direction and so they can really get
early indications of which diseases
you're likely to get and there's a lot
of information you can even get from
just phone usage but what all this bio
tracking technology really reminds me of
is a quote I read from evil Noah Harare
is but commodious which is that the 20th
century medicine was all about healing
the thick but now it's about upgrading
the health and that's not necessarily a
bad thing
their concern is well for those who get
this additional health are also the ones
that have the wealth to afford the
health and so David correctly asks this
question in this book how will be
extends human health span with equity
equality and human decency because as
David says unless aging is recognized as
disease once we know that some of these
supplements actually do have an effect
preventing aging there will only be
available for those who can afford them
because they won't just be prescribed
because you've got aging and that's a
disease and so what happens if those who
have the wealth to afford these
supplements they get better health they
don't have more time to make more wealth
and then they have more wealth to make
being able to afford even more
supplements and say oh it's just a
perpetual cycle and the idea is how can
we avoid this from happening and so
that's one problem that David address as
well but the second one is prefer that a
lot of people have about overpopulation
which David also dresses very well but
also talks about it in terms of instead
of overpopulation
it's about our overuse of consumption
and so the message is an all doom and
gloom but David does really reinforce
the point that we need to be spreading
this message and just having these
conversations now before it's too late
so yes I really do like how this book
addresses both the science and societal
impacts and the biggest say current I
mean it was only last year that who
recognized old age in the International
classification of diseases and if you
need another reason there's also a
lovely quote from Winnie the Pooh which
is when I'm here what is it and piglet
replies it's today and Connie Deepika my
favorite day I love that quote so I hope
this videos given you a good overview of
what the book is about but as you can
see the book is big and there is much
more to read then I can say in a
12-minute summary so go read the book
and there's honestly thanks to David for
such an insightful book so as always
thanks for listening